[Music]
he looks like me
identity is an edinburgh festival
perennial which shows a plenty about
migration and refugees safety and
belonging
[Music]
never more so than in a year of war
someone comes along in 1999
to sort it all out
you know who he is
he is who you think of when you think of
russia today
imperial delusion casts a shadow across
the post-soviet arctic in nightlands a
psychological thriller about russia and
the rise of vladimir putin
what happened decades later russia's
invasion of ukraine is the fabric of
czech ukrainian circus and dance act
boom
a show of youthful resilience in the
face of adversity
it goes boom because it's explosion of
young energy
also we have a lot of
traditions in in the show czech and
ukrainian traditions and
pretty much it's about like our freedom
there are journey tales across land and
borders of discovery and self-awareness
the ultimate audience journey though is
simply deciding what to watch in a
bewildering sea of choice
then you come across a guy who's a
british irish palestinian working doctor
who's also a comedian and a clown
my dream is to be able to make a show
that will make anyone anywhere in the
world laugh that's really what i want
i kind of wanted to explore my own
identity a little bit um and
that identity is very complicated you
want to see a show but it was
for me it was a first-hand experience of
how
different the the the differences in the
people who make up this country are see
you later
cheers well i don't think it's unique to
the people being british i think it's
just um something that people aren't
familiar with and that's to be expected
um and so my job is to bridge that gap
and to sort of say hey guys come come on
this journey with me i know it's
unfamiliar i know it's a bit different
but come on this journey with me it'll
be worth it
thank you very much
[Applause]
jonah al jazeera edinburgh